to be with us
unfortunately would somebody like to
move that apology be sustained
thank you councillor mctinnell and
secondary councillor macphail
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried before we move on to
[Music]
the other items we do have a slight
alteration to the agenda today and i'll
get the chief executive to just explain
what's happening there
yes thanks your worship um we have uh
the item on the procurement policy uh
the officer
responsible is currently on holiday and
because there are some minor amendments
we'd like to make to that
policy that's before you would like to
withdraw that and bring it back next
month
with the officer uh being present in
relation to the items
in respect of the draft long-term plan
and and as a result of that if adopted
the striking the rates resolution there
has been
a late breaking change um which has
meant that
the adoption the plan will probably have
to be deferred by one week
there is however a silver lining is to
do with a water rate on the otama water
scheme
which will ask lorna strath our chief
financial officer who can give you an
update about
where the process is at but more
importantly what that potential silver
lining might represent
thank you steve lorna uh yes thank you
your worship
so with with the change in the otama
water rate uh what that actually means
for the district is that we are now
looking at an average rates increase of
6.42
we are currently waiting on the auditors
to come back and verify the numbers and
we hope to present that next week so
um everything is sitting there it's
looking good we're ready to go we're
just
waiting on the auditors thank you okay
um so moving on into item two
declaration of counsellor conflicts of
interest is there any
new conflicts of interest needing to be
declared tonight
or anything in particular in this agenda
that needs to be
declared does not thank you um
we'll move on to confirmation of the
minutes of previous meetings so
confirmation in the minutes of the
ordinary meeting of council held
tuesday 8 june would somebody like to
move that that be seen as a true and
correct record
councillor reads secretary councillor
dixon thank you
are there any alterations required to
that record
council council grant
thank you worship i believe on
page 10 resolution number six the key
intersection changes i believe that
the key intersection changes that were
made during the it started
starting here during the trial such as
eagle street birch lane and crew street
artwork street i think that crew street
artwork street was
supposed to say barry street
and what's the other one in this section
wigan because because sarah thanks peter
because their roundabouts
was done above that and that
if my memory is correct i couldn't
actually find it on the net
when they go in to have a look at it but
i think that those key intersection
changes were to stay
uh was the uh yeah crew street uh rick
street should read barry street wigan
okay thank you councillor grant is
everybody comfortable with that
that alteration okay
that being so um i'll put the motion
with that alteration all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors um
confirmation of the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of council held
tuesday
nine june will someone like to move that
that be seen as a true and correct
record
councillor davis do i have a senator for
that
councillor heisted thank you are there
any alterations to that record that
needs to be made
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
um confirmation in the minutes of the
meeting of the community strategy
committee held wednesday 23 june some
would like to move that that be seen as
a true and correct record
councillor dixon do i have a second
offer that councillor macphail
thank you is there any alteration
required
to the record does not i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
the motion against the motion is carried
um are there any recommendations that
need to be confirmed
in that one
don't think they're all received weren't
they yeah
okay right um urgent light business
is there any urgent light business that
needs to be tabled
there's not um thank you
so we have um charlotte and sam
uh and mark with us from the youth
council today
and i know that they're pretty keen to
give us an update on
on what's happening so welcome along
and we're in your hands
and i think there are a couple of new
faces so we're
just assuring you that we're um we are
friendly
most the time
good afternoon councillors um it's a
privilege to be talking in front of you
so
uh thank you very much so um i'll start
us off by talking about youth week so
um this youth week uh a couple of months
ago i believe
um was a success um all those who
attended thoroughly enjoyed it but we
are looking at
changing it up just to add new interest
and get a new crowd of people along
we have also signed an agreement with
the electoral commission
so they will support us in our next
events
thank
youth awards we are looking at holding
them
at the end of the year in december
and the thing we want to do is
country and what and we've got
two guest speaker options first up
is stan walker and and the next one is
jack
tyne
okay um as you already know we um
are going to do speed dating um the
youth council is extremely excited
so you can look forward to some tough
questions
we have we have the idea of wanting to
do like a five
a five to ten year plan and one of it
and one of our ideas is to help the um
mlt fundraise for
special needs people and kids to go ice
skating again because their funding run
out
and i know they thoroughly enjoyed it
because i used to do it with them when i
went to school
nick and mark have also told us how um
they're really happy with
um how the youth council is going um
they say that we organize and report
everything ourselves and that they don't
have to do much
even though that the work they do is are
very valued so thanks to them
thank you council thanks sam
and uh thanks charlotte is it did it
okay and and thanks mark for the the
work that you're doing
with uh with youth council uh are there
any questions
of from of the youth council members
from
councillors or any comments at all
council grant
i think your worship uh thank you guys
for for coming along
just great to see that the youth awards
are back at the end of the year
they have been held in uh may i was last
year then
last year was code whatever but um nice
to see people
really supportive and the youth awards
are a great
event every year so have you got a date
for that yet or you're still working on
it
um i think we're still working on it we
do not have an exact date
okay just my just the thought i had get
in as early as you possibly can to
bookness and change theatre
thank you
okay look thank you guys thank you for
the
um the work that you're doing and it
sounds like
not only are you doing some really good
stuff but having some fun along the way
so
um keep it up thank you
you don't want to add anything mac do
you um
richard i'm just going to pass on uh
your worship and myself were at a
workshop on sunday
and one of the youth council that was
there was a very
very uh proactive young man named um i
think was jb
and he was a delightful to work with and
he uh came across very very well so
it's quite um it's quite nice to know
that
you guys are out there pushing things
along so yeah thank you very much
thanks nick i should have asked you if
you wanted to make any comment
oh look at that
there we go here we go um yeah they've
been really busy really loud
loud bunch it's good to work with um
they've got plenty of ideas
um but they still get to at the end of
the end of the day they get to a
decision
um and they stick with it and yeah it's
it's great to work with
they're fully behind each other um yeah
so
makes it does make life quite easy on
the youth council but yeah
yeah very interesting at the same time
so and the fact that um yeah the few
other
people are coming on board and
supporting the youth council and that so
um
yeah good future ahead of us good cheers
yeah
thank you thank you nick and uh thank
you sam and charlotte and mark
okay um we'll move on then and we're
up to item 6
and we have a an item
from the facilities facilities
administration officer
with regard to time and temperature
displays
uh in the center of gore so is
that you kneel you're going to make some
comments there
any more comments but in relation to uh
if anybody's got any questions
okay leave hands going up everywhere um
doug
thank you worship uh thanks neil
i've been uh quite often approached
about that what's happening to the clock
where is it what's it doing or
sorry the time um no not the time
temperature cage
and uh interesting to see that we've now
got an option of having the uh
a time in and a gauge
um just a thought you've got you've got
in here
a wi-fi adventure
because the new the new clock would be
controlled
by um either a laptop or a iphone tablet
that sort of
and your wi-fi range is 10 to 15 meters
there's no actual free wi-fi and gore at
the moment hasn't been operating for
quite a while
any plans to how you're going to hook
that up
just that question because
at the moment the wi-fi is down because
the moonshine
redevelopment because the fire fibre is
based there
it has been worked on at the moment by
wireless and it tells me that it'll be a
very short
period of time cbd will have the free
wi-fi back up
good great thanks
thank you your worship i'm in support of
this recommendation that we have
upgraded versions and i just do have two
comments
one is that hopefully the color that we
choose is easily visible from a distance
and of a reasonable size i don't know
how that works but
um and the other thing is have the
families and the organisations who
donated those
gifts originally to the town both matera
and gore
have they been contacted and let know
that there's a change on
i would kneel yeah through worship no
they specifically haven't been contacted
uh the the clock from material is still
available as a as it is even though it's
not
not functioning so if it was for a
purpose or anything
then the one from gore kiki lines
it's actually in auckland
because they were going to have a look
and see whether they could do anything
with it
and but they will give us a um a certain
amount
that they can purchase parts off it so
it will go towards the price
yeah thank you neil i just think as a
courtesy maybe that's
a letter is appropriate just to
acknowledge the fact that they have been
donations to the ratepayers of the
district
thank you good good point um
neville thank you euresha um
i'm just a little bit concerned about
this because uh the material community
would have
asked on more than one occasion in
regards to the clock
and it's been told that it's um can't be
repaired etc etc
and yet it comes to full council without
any negotiation to the community board
um i'd like to think that the council
withhold its funding its unbudgeted
funding for
these two this item for mater at the
moment until such time as the material
community board has a discussion
about the clock whether it wants to
retain it how it's going to inform
the former um presenter of the clock
who was mctullick well-known and
businessman and mayor of matera
i've had discussion with the chairman
and he would like that
put forward that that the community
board would like to have a discussion
about this for us before
before they make it and bring it back to
the council what their decision will be
look i think both those requests can be
accommodated
without too much problem it's not as if
this is going to happen tomorrow
so i think well certainly my
my support is behind this and i get the
feeling that most of the councils would
like to see this happen
i think the community board needs to
have some say in in perhaps
location and and what it might look like
and
and if they are keen to come connect
with
the talik family then i've got no
problem with that at all
i guess just from my perspective i want
to make sure that
for the future we've got
ability to add or change things on the
on the display and i'm just thinking
about
um the likes of as we
we get a little bit more connected to
and aware of
some of the environmental issues in our
communities
and in our nation i know that uh
on more than one occasion i've had
approaches with regard to
carbon registering carbon metering
and and i think that you know while
i'm not sure whether that's appropriate
right now or not but i think at some
point in time it's
it may well be and who knows
with the space for it so so if there's
a possibility that we can we can have a
device that's going to allow for one two
three or four
different displays then i think that
would be
useful i think also
something else that i regularly get
contacted about with regard to the
the temperature gauge in gore is the
visibility
from particularly from south going north
and and i think that that's something
that needs to be discussed with
the parks and reserves manager just to
see if we can
improve that visibility somewhat
i'm also very mindful that probably
not all but there will be a good
percentage of the vehicles that are
using that road now
have got temperature gauges and clocks
in them
as well so so i think that
it's important to have something like
that for a certain section of the
community
but probably the relevance for the whole
community may not be quite as high as it
once was
so with um
with notice being taken of the points
that council phillips has made with
regard to
community board involvement in location
and recognition of the previous
donations
would somebody like to move that the
report we received
and that will go ahead with um with this
particular item
counselor reed double signal for that
council on the file thank you
counselor dixon sorry worship i just
have a question
um whether we're doing single-sided or
double-sided
costs so okay um neil do you want to
make a comment on that
the the one that was currently down
in main street um until recently
um it was double-sided
so the intention is double-sided that's
the intention yeah
okay i'm sure you'll keep us appraised
of
the progress on on this one uh i'll put
that
um
well we're talking about funding and
for the the purchase and the
installation
so i don't think that precludes the
discussions that
council phillips was raising before does
it
yeah you worship it it may be that the
community board may decide that they
want to
retain the clock as it is
i think i think if if um
so this recommendation be put forward
but also make a recommendation that if
the material community board so wishes
to change its clock to
one of these digital devices that the
money be set aside for them
okay so i'll need an amendment for that
so do you want to move an amendment
against of course
yeah i'm moving to memphis so
so how would you like that to read um
so we can start probably with uh
anywhere
so we've got two two recommendations
there now do you want to add another one
okay so that uh where it says that the
both units
be installed that we could put in that
the unbudget
and budgeted funding for the material be
left until the material community board
has had discussion about the clock
and then put forward its recommendation
to council
okay do i have a second of that
amendment
so council then fail okay
so i guess what i'm hearing is that
we're
we're looking at receiving the report
um making uh an allocation available
subject to the third
point which would be discussion
to occur at the material committee board
around style
and location and connection with
previous owners
or donators is that right
and whether or not if they want to
retain the clock yeah yeah yeah
so can i just uh counselor davis
just a question on that um through your
worship does the price that you've got
um yeah for two
instead of getting one and then another
one later so is
does it affect the price thank you
can i ask susan have you managed to get
something out of this
perfect and that's been
moved by councillor phillips and
seconded by councillor macphail
so i'll put the amendment all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried um
so the amendment becomes the motion i'll
put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye against the motion
is carried thank you councillors
right we'll move on then to um item
seven
and a pretty substantial item and one
that's going to
be connected with this council for a
long time around the table i believe
so wastewater discharge consent renewal
we have a
report from the three waters asset
manager
and i'll ask matt to speak shortly but
steve do you want to make any comment on
this before i asked matt
just to say worship this is a major
long-term project
that will be the subject of considerable
scrutiny
and therefore a working party
that with major stakeholders to arrive
at the
most optimum solution is in our view a
good idea
but it's likely that this issue will
ultimately be
subsumed by three waters reform given
the long-term nature of
the consent application process
so i think that's as long as the
council's recognised this is the
another step and what is a long-term
journey
but will ultimately lead to a step
change that will be needed in wastewater
treatment okay thank you um
matt do you want to talk us through this
particular
item thank you worship
um yeah i'll just take the report as
read um
the only thing i'd probably add to it is
um the technical working group met
last week um and
probably agreed on a first tranche of
work that we're going to complete
hopefully over the next six weeks and
that's around
identifying some potential land disposal
areas
so that'll be initially a desktop
assessment
and it will look at general areas for
disposal rather than specific properties
and from that we're hoping to to move to
a short list
of preferred areas and and disposal
methods
for further investigation and at that
point would probably
potentially look at doing some some
on-site
investigation to determine
the right soil characteristics for the
disposal methods that we're looking at
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you matt so
open for discussion or comment from
any councillors council grant then
councillor davis
thank you worship matt what what size
what area would we need for land
disposal
for the storage box
uh so that that's very much dependent on
the
um the disposal method that we use
um
in theory what would be the worst case
scenario i mean
we had the options from lakes district
or queensland lakes district council
what they were doing
so if you if you used uh a similar
similar to what they were doing for land
disposal what would you
what's your largest area is it going to
be 40 hectares or
80 yeah so through the the
original concentric location that we
locked with environment southam
we looked at some land treatment options
and they required some substantial
areas of land i think for a worst case
scenario
from memory it was about 600 hectares
for gore um
yeah so that is obviously um not
particularly practical
um so what we're looking at now is um
as a treatment a treatment system or a
treatment plant that would treat the
water to a quite a high standard
and then disposing it to land and that
significantly reduces the
the area of land that you need
those options some some of the options
that we're looking at at a high level uh
obviously some some irrigation options
and off the top of my head i think
with with the so with the biological
nutrient
removal plant that would reduce the the
area to i think
is between depending on um
a few things between sort of 60 and 150
hectares
so it substantially reduces it one of
the other options that we're looking at
is and this is what's been installed at
queenstown is a rapid infiltration
system
so that's i guess in simple terms
it's almost like a large soak hole um so
obviously
the wastewater needs to be treated to a
very high standard before you apply it
to that
um but that would you know be a matter
of um
sort of you know in the vicinity of say
five hectares or something like that
um so it's significantly reduced again
um so yeah yeah
there's a lot of work to do to to fully
understand
things than that but um but certainly
yeah
the initial work that we've done
suggests that land treatment
is not particularly viable because of
southland's weather and
soil characteristics and things like
that so we're trying to find
options where we land disposal
downstream of a you know a
sophisticated treatment plant will work
yeah
thank you council davis
now through your worship just uh a
question about the
consents i see matera has already
expired so what happens in that sort of
situation
where where does council sit yeah so
um the the specific
um allowance in the rma for this
uh for the situation um and
providing that um a renewal application
is
submitted um before a certain date
before that consent expires
um the the regional council can
grant grant us with continuance rights
which effectively means that we operate
under our existing consent
until a new consent is issued um so
we've been issued with the the
continuance rights for both our consents
council macphail just three worship for
matt um it probably
leads on from councillor davis there so
what
how long like how long will that give
you the continuance
is there a set set time or is it just
until the consensus issue
do we have a time frame my understanding
and keith may be able to add to this but
my understanding is there's no specific
time frames on it and i think it would
probably be
provided that the applicant which the
council in this case is
you know making reasonable progress um
to to get a new consent
then then it would be acceptable as far
as i'm aware there's no specific time
frames
but i'll ask keith to them
that's correct there is no specific time
frame it is
discretionary for the regional council
to either grant or not grant
a continuance and
keeping them up to date with progress is
an essential part of that
thank you keith um councillor heisted
you thanks you worship um just to matt
matt i enjoyed your report it was
actually
a good read and what is up to speed on
the uh cultural issues and i guess you
touched on it on a new report but
separation of human waste from animal
waste
in terms of what's going into those
ponds it says there that there's it need
to be have
more research done whether the animal
waste would need to be treated
differently to human waste from a
spiritual context as opposed to the
the water quality standard is there no
information available on
on that i i reading it seemed to very
much focused on
human waste needing to be needing to be
cleansed by the earth
do we have any information on the on the
other volumes because it must be a fair
volume
going through the through our poems
yes so um yeah there is certainly
um a difference of um
perspective when it comes to the human
and animal waste
we do have a reasonable understanding
of the the proportions of
of trade waste versus domestic waste
i think the comment that you're
referring to is in the hakanoi runanga
memo and and that was referring to how
the animal waste can be treated um
yeah so so that is sort of i guess
further
work that we um that we need to do we
have had some discussions
with um key trade waste users
around potentially um separating out the
trade waste flows
and it very much is an option for
particularly the larger users
and and it does um open up some
different
avenues for treatment and disposal
so yeah it is something else that we
need to consider going forward yeah
thank you um council dixon
um thank you worship i just have a
question for me
some um overseas councils and and
companies are actually
drying waste and then applying it to
land
could that be a possibility in this case
so did you say drying drying drying the
waste
so it forms a powder yeah
and then being able to apply it to less
land because it's more in less water
yes i mean that that is an option um i
think what you're
possibly referring to is the sludge
that's produced
from the treatment process yes um and
and yeah that very much is an option it
can be
applied um not dried as well um
i guess the the trick is is removing the
water and
and getting it dry which can be you know
considering the the proportion of water
that you've got to remove
is quite high um it can be a difficult
task
to achieve but um but yeah there are all
options and
um i guess the you know with the the
nutrient removal treatment plant that
we're proposing
um very much um it creates a separate
um sludge waste stream that that we will
have to
come up with a strategy to deal with i
mean and drying
drying that sludge is one option before
disposal
thank you matt okay um
castor garden
with the um question from matt is with
the new company
if we vote to go to the new company at
the end of the year
all this stuff will just roll over into
that or how does it no one really knows
how that happens
um yeah so that's something that we have
had a discussion
um in the working party um around
um and you're probably right there's
quite a lot of uncertainty around that
at the moment
um i guess the working party's thoughts
on it are that
um you know if we can aim to make as
much progress as possible
um and in the meantime um then that will
put us put the community in the best
place to get a wastewater treatment
plant upgrade as soon as possible and
potentially other
ahead of you know other towns when that
new entity
or if that new entity does get formed
i guess essentially as as i said this is
the beginning of quite a long journey
for for this council and it has been
raised it may well not be this council
that concludes
that journey but um we've got a lot of
learnings to
take on board as we get along and as i
found it really interesting
and enlightening to read the
documentation you've put together
for this one matt so thank you um
thank you for that um good job it's a
question
councillor phillips thanks you russia i
just like to think that
working party would would think about
some sort of drying system
in the aspect of of because the council
has
a very low power rate that we should be
thinking very seriously about power
as a cream a clean a green alternative
to
drying sludge etc so yeah
there is there is um products out there
that's available and
i think we should be thinking that that
aspect as well good point
okay um unless there's any other
questions i just want to say thank you
matt for
for the work you've done so far and uh
for the work that's
about to come um would somebody like to
move the recommendations
be received thank you councillor davis
signing to council grant
thank you is there any discussion on
those
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried thank you um we'll move on
then to item
8 and rural roads working party
and we have a an item with some
recommendations we also have a
letter that's been tabled for
councillors to consider
as well from mr hugh guardin
so peter do you want to make any comment
to the
to the item before i open it up for
discussion
there we go sorry for every year
this was born about by two items
of um there's interest here in the
council with what's happening with rural
roads and there was a petition that was
submitted
and it sort of gave rise to the need for
for a working party it was also
my asset management plan that we've put
together
i strongly suggested in fact that we did
have a working party where we had
representatives from a council that
worked with staff
uh just some of the strategic things
that we have in front of us going for
in the future so it was born from it
mainly okay
um so just with regard to the
recommendation do you have any
particular thoughts around
rural representation on that working
party
which yeah i think i've got a couple of
names
being presented down there but really
volunteers i suppose
it's some of the rural councillors
steve do you want to come yeah i think
uh so you worship i think
peter has worshipped referring to
whether there should be
other members of the rural community
that should sit on this working party
and that was the initial intention of
the council
at the time of the ltp deliberative
meeting
then i detected some
minor revision and thought in that and
that's why the recommendation before you
is
sans community representation
however i think you worship if the
council is of a mood to
include external rural
people from the community on the working
party the best way would be to give the
working party the power to co-opt
and let the working party select both
the number
and the actual identities
of those members that should boost or
bolster
the working party thank you for that
and i think the rural
users input is going to be pretty
valuable to
um the way forward so i think the
suggestion of co-option
on to that committee is a good idea okay
it's
open for discussion councils
council davis i think you worship i
think co-opting is uh
is the way forward for this particular
group
and i would move in that direction
okay so i i guess are you moving the uh
recommendation
with the inclusion of co-opting in the
makeup of the
committee so
is there a seconder for that motion
councillor macphail thank you
and did you want to comment councilman
carl you're just really um
supporting what we've got there uh in
regard to the fact of
um obviously acknowledge uh
mr gardiner's leader and obviously the
commentary in there
um and we do understand that the
recommendation does have a
uh arranging a meeting between the
representatives of mountain road but i
think we're also going to look at
having a meeting with um representatives
in relation to that
that other working group in in the
waikaki area i think between myself and
councillor guardian we can facilitate
that along with the other working
working members supportive of the
co-opting
i think that people that have the um
practical knowledge and
and a bit of sense out there in regard
to what's happening with those roads
they're um they're not silly about it
they know that um the seasonal damage
and and the areas that were missing
we're missing the um
the actual timings and when we can get
in and get that work done
and that's probably uh comes down to a
lot of local knowledge
so the correct people in the correct
place co-oped it and we'll be able to
give us some valuable input to
to actually achieving our goal which is
um hopefully
get through this winter and next season
where i'm into some better road
servicing
okay thank you councilman fail
councillor hosted
you always have a question i know it's a
working party as opposed to committee
but
second council was given power to co-op
should there be in terms of reference
developed so it's quite clear what the
gambit of the working party is
especially external members belts and
braces
good point and i think that
probably could be left in your hands as
chief executive
yes sure i mean the um roadie manager
has concentrated on the type of topics
that the working party would engage in
but yes we can certainly as per
our other subcommittees put in terms of
reference
incorporating these topics but also
giving
setting up parameters that yes the
powder cropped and
what um powers to act
um need to be there so for example i
wouldn't visit a working party needs to
come back to the council
if they're just what i call out in the
field directives that need to be given
about anything with a more significant
budgetary budgetary impact
uh would i would suggest the council
might want to actually approve that
rather than leave it to the working
party so certainly happy to draft
uh some terms of reference worship but
it would need to be approved by the full
council
i don't think you want the working party
to draft the same terms of reference and
approve them do you
i guess we're likely to be meeting as a
council
within the next 10 days is that right so
we could consider that reasonably
smartly
as well but good point okay so we
we have a motion is there any further
discussion required there's not i'll put
that motion
which includes the co-option of uh of
um additional members all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
item nine has been held over uh we're
now on to item 10 which is the otama
rural water scheme and
proposed transfer of ownership again
another discussion point that's been
going for
quite some time and i think we're
rapidly getting to a closure
on this one which is is really good um
some interesting uh
attachments to this uh particular item
and i'm sure that they'll um
they'll form the thing inform the
thinking of
of the populace out there who use the
scheme
when they consider the ownership
and the operation of the scheme going
forward
so it it's open well
just the chip is either do you want to
make a comment before i open it and then
we'll open it for discussion
i think it's reasonably self-explanatory
worship
the question before the council really
is are you satisfied that there is
sufficient information to be able to put
this
to the consumers of the scheme
before they are invited to make a choice
on whether to
agree to the transfer of ownership to
the new company
or to retain the status quo so the
referendum will be
reasonably simply put in terms of
question and the information that you
approve
must be in the hands of consumers before
that referendum is
distributed to consumers
okay it's open for discussion
and or recommendation council guidelines
yeah i'd like to recommend the um um
ocean but um just the company's probably
got a last chance to have a go at this
with the reforms coming up and basically
it's going to we had a meeting with the
regulator um and basically he presented
it pretty strongly to them that if they
don't perform
they would be absorbed into the company
and or taken over by the council and
would be handed straight over to the
company so basically they've got a
chance to perform or not perform and
they've also got a vote to get through
first so basically people have got to
vote uh whether they want to go go with
the company or want to go with the
regulator
or the new company coming up so it's
quite there's a wee window
belief that they can do this in and
they've got the bill they put through
had a five-year window for them to do it
but
i think that five-year window will close
pretty closely by the end of this year
yeah so probably we need to move
reasonably quickly to have a vote
to see if people want to go hmm
yeah thank you councillor garden um is
there any further discussion
somebody like to move the
recommendations that are included and
they're fairly straightforward
councillor guardin
moved seconded a councillor mctinnell
is there any discussion on that this is
not i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
and and i guess from here we organize
the
referendum is that right yes you
should we'll need to establish a role of
electors for the referendum and then
it's governed by the local electoral act
2001
which is off the top of my head an
89-day
process from commencement
that's right okay
okay um that takes us on to item 11
which is uh resource management
delegations
and we have some delegations here um
it's keith speaking to us keith do you
want to lead us through this one
certainly thank you your worship um so
the purpose of the report
is really twofold one is to deal with
delegations to the property
group and secondly looking at commission
commissioner delegations and
appointments
moving forward so the property group are
taking over responsibility for assisting
council with its resource management
functions
both in terms of plan development plan
changes that occur
and the processing of resource consents
and put simply what is being proposed is
that the
experienced staff who are processing
consents
it is appropriate for them to have the
same delegations as
staff at council and other consultants
that we've been using
in recent years for making decisions on
the processing
of those consents but not the final
decision on the proposal
um as well um separate
um so there's two staff at the property
group who'll be processing consents and
the recommendation is for those
delegations to apply in the same way
as existing staff there are two more
senior
and more experienced staff at the
property group
that it's proposed to be given the
delegations to actually make decisions
on those applications where there is
nothing
in contention which is 95 to 98
of the consent that we get so in the
same way
that myself and others have signed off
making decisions on consents in that
category
um the two people at the property group
who are separate from the two that are
processing the consents
will have that delegation and
arising from that
then consideration is also worth looking
at at this time in terms of
the commissioners that we've appointed
in recent years
and the i guess the setup that we have
for those
and there are four commissioners
that have let their status as a
commission elapsed that we've previously
appointed
and it's appropriate for them to come
off the list
and with the two additional ones being
appointed to make decisions from the
property groups
it really does remove the need for david
puller to be
used on a continuing basis but i made
the comment in the report that david has
made a significant contribution
to the resource management function
sitting on the
group that considered the first district
plan and have
made himself available to consider
processing of consents
from 1995
so with with the additional ones being
considered in the
low number of other ones of a more
significant nature
then mr puller's continuing involvement
doesn't isn't required
the other change that's proposed to the
delegations and the appointment i guess
in neutral terms is that the existing
planning consultant has agreed to
make himself available and a commission
a basis if council
wishes there are several
other uh councillors and mr dean crystal
um who have delegations as commissioners
and they are set out at the bottom of
page 143
and with them um being available
though i see councillor high state
expires in a couple of months time
with his delegations um
with the ford that we've got available
there it's unlikely that we'll need
other commissioners going forward in the
mid-term
so there's a series of recommendations
on page
144 and then the tables that goes with
them which really provides a
summary of the extensive delegations
that are provided for
under the rma both for processing of
consents
and for plan changes
should they arise i just want to note in
the first recommendation i have spelt
the name of joe
cruz incorrectly i can promise the
council that no further reports that i
submit to council would have such a
spelling mistake in them
happy to answer any questions thank you
keith
um yeah this is a significant change uh
for council in the way that we uh
we approach our resource um
responsibilities uh i think it makes a
lot of sense
um and and i just want to
touch on the point that keith made
around the contribution that david
puller's made
to this council over a long period of
time
um i had the privilege of sitting around
the table with david as a counsellor
initially
and then after that he decided to get
involved in the
the rma side of things and has served
this council well
so so i would like to just acknowledge
and i think that recommendation does do
that the commitment
and the contribution he has made it's
open for discussion counsellors and or
recommendation
counselor grant thank you worship so
so this is basically the end of the
council planning department
is it in-house
we we still have one we still have one
employee
is that correct who's with us
yes through your worship yes that's
correct uh there is a vacancy for a
senior planner
uh and that is still in train
but the property group in effect
is going to replace the services that
mr hovel has provided for such a
considerable period of time and in fact
i was going to at the right time to just
acknowledge that mr hovel this is
actually going to be keith's
last meeting with the full council and
so there will be a separate function to
acknowledge his feats but in the public
setting it needs to be acknowledged that
keith came to us on one july
2013 uh and for 18 years has provided
high level reliable and accurate advice
in this very difficult area for this
council and
community and
not many consulting type of arrangements
last that long many marriages last a lot
shorter than that
but this has been a very good union and
i speak as chief executive
and keith has been a a tower of support
um and over the years has become
one of the crew in terms of being deemed
to be just
it's keith but the staff treat him as
just one of our team
and i know that the councillors have had
a rich experience with establishing a
great rapport
and that rapport has been evident in the
district planned committee
meetings which ongoing and have had to
require a sensitive
transition from keith to the property
group
but the worshiper i think it's
appropriate at this point in time that
the council certainly knows
keith in a public setting he has made
massive contributions
and will leave very big shoes to fill we
do try and tempt him from time to time
to be kind of like a granddaddy
consultant that we can wheel in and
uh when we get into the real sticky
stuff um
he's resisted those um urgings at this
stage but we still
live in some hope but certainly from my
perspective your worship from an
operational point of view
we are very sad to see keith go and we
will be making obviously some
acknowledgement
um about the the eminence in the
departure
in the very near future yeah and look i
um acknowledged the comments and
endorsed the comments that have been
made and
and i wasn't aware this was your last
meeting keith so
so my apologies for not meeting um
mentioning it prior
but the the commitment and the
connection you've had with this council
does go back a long time and i remember
some of my early connections with you
and and just how much comfort you were
able to give me
in terms of the processes that we were
undertaking
things that um were pretty tricky
uh at the time in my mind but she made
it
so common sense and sensible that
it works very very well i'm i'm really
encouraged to see that you're taking up
the role as a
commissioner and i note that you have
shifted your residence to google
district so
it's not going to be as if we're not
going to see you but
it will be quite different to not seeing
you around this table so
thank you keith for the contribution
you've made
okay opening it up for discussion
recommendations yeah i'd like to move
those recommendations
and uh i'll just just say that uh for
the first
couple of years keith when i arrived
here as a counselor from 2012
i actually thought you were one of the
staff because you
yeah you just fitted in so well so uh
good luck on your so-called retirement
but
we will probably see you around again
thanks
thank you worship um in the evidence of
our
chairman councillor bulger i'd just like
to endorse the
previous speakers in regards to keith
as part of the district plan committee
i'd just like to thank you keith for
the smooth transition between yourself
and the property group and
your knowledge that you've passed on to
us in the last
my last term in this tournament as a
counsellor
and i wish you all the best in your
retirement and i'd just like to think
that you as a super sup
come in every now and again thank you
very much
thank you neil okay so we have
a motion that we have a mover of a
motion
that um the recommendations be
um passed
do you see your second signature
counselor guideline thank you
any further comment does not i'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right and that brings us on to
rethinking waste management
some big weighty
before us as as we move to
through this year so we have a report
from the roading asset manager and also
the facilities
admin officer so peter and neal
and i thank you for the report you have
made
um before i ask either of you to make
any comment
do you want to make any comment steve
okay so um peter
neil do you want to make any comment at
this point in time
um pre-worship this very much is a
report back from
the working group that was set up
um two items of business really were
uh um the fees and charges they were we
wanted to to have addressed
um there's a number of reasons for uh
for the need for rise and the other item
is
just some structure um in terms of
reference from
the focus groups they were looking to
set up within the community
so just working through that okay
neil was the other person mentioned do
you want to make any comment
uh through your worship the um what
peter i endorse what peter says
and one of the main concerns about the
fee
structure is the impact of the increased
dealings with clean fill and green waste
and i think the best just if we answer
any questions later on
okay so counselor hosted
you thanks russia um yeah i think it's
important to note that the
you know the greenways charges were
waived during the coveted environment
and council's now turning its mind too
it's it's previous position but
once you have a question around
definition probably through your worship
what is the difference between a small
load and a large trailer
is there such a thing as a small trailer
or is it a boot load
what is what is the what does that mean
for your worship we just tend to have
standard trailers and and tandem axle
right so be a single axle as opposed to
a tennis
standard trailer thank you
okay so there really is two components
to this report there's the
fees and charges that that we need to
consider and
um and adopt but i think there's also
an equally important one and possibly
more important one
um around how we connect
with our community uh and the relative
agencies
in terms of what the way forward for
dealing with waste in this district is
going to look like
there's no doubt that it's getting more
complex um there's more requirements
around what we
can and what we can't do and there's
certainly
a lot of opinions right across our
community as to what is good and what is
not so good
so i think we need to take this time to
pause
and connect and do that in the most
user-friendly way that we possibly can
so so hopefully
we'll we'll work through that tonight
but in terms of
the first item the fees and charges
is there any particular items there that
need to be
discussed right now councilman mcfarland
no
there's just a commentary there
regarding the regional
uh charge comparison and uh looking at
what we've actually done
in the last couple of work or setting up
these working groups
i think it's important that the
community sees what's actually
realistically costing us
to take to remove the rubbish and the
weight of the rubbish being taken from
the town and having to be disposed out
of the area
which is probably key to the fact that
the working parties need to work out
what
we can actually retain within the
township and and recycle
but we still sit in the median range
there even with um
with the increase so and it's obviously
one of the
one of the challenges that will face the
working party if we can trim that off we
save yourself some money
which may be reflected in rates at some
stage
i think the the fees and charges are
realistic as a way forward
for the for the future you know there's
probably
um a lot of people in our community
including myself who can recall days
when
it was free to go to the dump and you
just could dump whatever you liked when
you wanted to do
and we wanted to largely that
regime has completely changed and i
think that's a welcome
change certainly from an environmental
perspective it is
and i've got no doubt that it's going to
get more stringent as time goes on
so um
unfortunately there is a cost that goes
with that and the cost
is going to be levied on the community
council read
thank you your worship excuse me just a
question for
peter the commercial cost is that coming
in
under the bulk the bulk disposal charge
is that for commercial operators
correct thank you we just tried to make
that decision that
um some of the larger operators were
caught in the
nether such yeah no that's good um i
just wonder too if possibly the focus
group
particularly for some of our local
residents just clarify
exactly what some of our local councils
in the area are actually doing with
their waste
i think that would be a good opportunity
for locals to see that
we're not the only people with problems
and yeah we just need to look very
carefully at what we're doing
council dixon thank you worship
i'm really pleased to see that there's
going to be a focus group and that you
will ask members of the community
for ideas because there's a lot of good
ideas and experience
out there and i guess for us all that
reducing waste is both an environmental
and a cost
saving for ratepayers so i think um
it's really good that the focus group is
being set up be quite good to see an
open
forum for people to come along as well
and
just engage with the focus group okay
and the suggestion of before we get on
to that is there
any other issues around fees and charges
okay so if we move on to the way forward
uh in terms of a working party um
largely made up of
councillors and um i guess
individuals or
individuals organizations that are
already connected to
um to waste and the focus group
that is really looking to engage
wider in the community to look at the
alternatives
and and also some education around
waste going forward councilman fell
just working through there with the
commentary regarding the focus group
through the working party
um we probably don't want to get
ourselves
too bogged down with the
the the actual aspect of taking it
through to that next group but i think
it's important
when that focus group um starts its work
or starts looking at it
there may be others that go through to
that working party that have
ideas that we we actually established
because we sort of um
we've put some parameters around the
people there but there could be people
that come out that are actually quite
valuable
and would be a real asset in that
working party uh the other thing in
regard to the focus group i'm not sure
counsellor-wise we're whether we still
want all the
the councillors want to be involved in
that whether it's a time
time you know
the time that goes into that focus group
that maybe uh
i'd be quite happy that if if they
needed one counsellor to to be involved
in that and then bring it back to the
working party
um i'll put that in there
it may expediate some of the some of the
actions
so the council is involved uh
yourself brett and cliff cliff's not
here
brett do you have a view on that
thank you you know i agree with richard
i think the focus group should be
least counsellor centric and more
community focused i think you ever roll
the worship
personally and perhaps there are other
councils around the table that have an
interest i think councilman dixon
has a particular interest in this area
not necessary
a duplication the working party it
almost looks like we've got two
you know two layers and it could be just
become a duplication and i do just
question whether that focus group will
actually meet
monthly it seems a pretty pretty big
task for
for that group yeah i was looking at
that in my mind i'm thinking it probably
should be as required
um and that might mean even more than
monthly in
in one occasion or on two occasions but
i
i think it should be as required i think
it's important too that there's a
an independent facilitator leading that
group
someone that's got skills in
facilitation not necessarily
skills in waste
but knows council processes knows the
scene
and is able to facilitate well
we're talking about 10 community members
on that group and i think that that's
probably a reasonable number where those
10 would come from
will be the next point for us
and i might just throw to the comms
officer or comms
manager just to give us some ideas on
how we might approach connecting with
the community
asking for people to be engaged in this
whole process
uh thank you through the chair i
understand that
the intention is to call for expressions
of interest from the public and we'll be
doing that through
our um our usual channels both um you
know our online and also
in the ensign notice build and um on
radio
there is um some criteria that i think
they've laid out around that as well so
once we get the experience of interest
because there probably will be a
commitment required from the
people that want to be involved in this
then we can go from there
yep okay
a new discussion on this
makeup process reporting back
i guess it is going to be an evolving
process as we
as we go through this but i think the
key
focus that has to be there all the time
is to get as much
input from a wider section of the
community as we possibly can
i guess my question is around the
independent facilitator do we really
need that like
is that not you you wish i'm more than
happy to be involved
i'm i'm also very aware that there are
some
particular views held quite strongly
around
council's involvement in waste and
ideas and waste so i guess that's really
what drives my
my view that there does need to be
somebody that does have
an independence um away from
council council mcfarland just thinking
uh
if we worship if the communications were
being done
whether we actually asked for interest
of an independent facilitator
and see what air if we cast the net and
see what we get
yeah that's right okay
um any other comments or questions
yeah your worship on there you've got uh
materia community board
uh to be advised as councillor phillips
you've you've ran the facility here in
gore for quite a number of years
as would your input be on here
or is that is that have the community
board decided who's going to sit on that
or
i believe the community um are unaware
of this at the moment so
they will have to go back to the meeting
yeah and there will be a representative
from the community board i'm sure that
uh it may not necessarily be me as uh as
i'm a counsellor for the ward
uh and a spokesperson for the
board at the council meeting so it would
be probably better
if there was a community board member
rather than myself
but i'm more than happy to pass on any
knowledge that i've had
okay um just a couple
of technical bits for me i guess um
in the constitution for the community
focus group
we talk about um a community member
to be advised i think it should be
community members just a missing
s on that one
and in the objective of the focus group
we
item e i'm just not sure
that that's the role of the focus group
i think it's more the role of the
working party
in terms of asking for expressions of
interest in a recovery center
that might be connected to the transfer
station
does anybody have any issues with those
two points okay
so with uh with the changes um
and the explanations that have been made
uh is there anything peter or neil that
you wish to add to that
if i can briefly just talk about e sorry
worship i think the intent there was
that models throughout the country
aren't necessarily
run by the community often they're run
by
outside organisations so there's
different models out there so i suppose
that was just opening the
suggestion it could come from a
community of different agencies
stepping forward i think it's um it's
absolutely vital that
that doesn't get discussed i'm just not
sure whether
and i was you know big to seek some
advice from the chief executive on this
one i think it's probably more
a role for the working group of council
as opposed to the focus group of the
community
um to call for expressions of interest
because we'd
i guess we'd have a role in framing what
that looks like
do you do you have any thoughts on that
steve
yes i through your wish i agree um
calling for expressions of interest is
really
uh it's a governance
slash operation uh core function of the
council
um and really that that process needs to
be run by the council as
distinct from the focus group so i would
support
it being that particular task being
transferred up to the
working party
okay so with my councilman fail
it just can confirmation regarding to
the uh terms of reference for that
the constitution i think will remove
councillor heisted and councillor bulger
from the constitution there um
because they are now they'll be their
next tear up where we bring that to the
working party
and it saves tying them up with that um
with that focus work
yep good point
okay with those changes in mind would
somebody like to move the adoption
of the recommendation on page 158
move council mcphail seconded councillor
dixon thank you
is there any discussion or amendment
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
again the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um item 13 social media platforms
and we have a uh a memo here from the
chief executive and also
uh report from the social media
platforms or the social media platform
um do you want to make a comment
steve and then sonia do you want to talk
to that
yeah thank you my comments will be
fairly brief because they uh
reasonably self-explanatory in my
covering memo
i thought it was important that uh you
receive both
um the expert operational advice
from a communications manager and my
more distant
and about senior management type
observation as to how social media
appears to opt
to operate fundamentally
mrs gurken and i have come to the same
conclusion that it's a valuable
platform for the council to operate
however i do have some concerns in the
area of
editorial policy and whether we're being
a bit too
kind and permissive and allowing those
with
fairly damaging behaviors
to dominate a platform which when i came
to the conclusion that
ultimately it might not serve the
purpose you wish which is to get a
widespread cross
section of the community to participate
in the
social media options we we have on offer
but if uh people fear that there'll be
retaliation through
just um toxic and defamatory
or just downright ugly comments that may
actually act as a disincentive for
people to participate which would be a
shame
so that was the only cautionary note i
had in my observations but
again me speaking to the merits of
different modern technological options
is almost an oxymoron
so i will defer to the the resident pro
and that of course is miss
cooking
thank you through the chair look there's
no denying that
social media can be a pretty toxic
environment at times
um and that's not helped by the fact
that there's a lot of bots out there
that actually troll and when they find
these negative conversations they'll
jump in so
as i mentioned it's probably a
resourcing issue as much as anything
because you need to actually
look at all those comments and then see
whether you're actually dealing with
real people or bots
so it's an interesting interesting
exercise but look
by and large we have a really good um
social media community
who um show respect and engage in
conversations and we get a lot of good
positive feedback so
you know um i think like i said like the
chief executive said it is
a place that we need to be to connect
with our community
when we have seen these
more challenging conversations there
usually been issues that have been
challenging
elsewhere for our customer service staff
and on other other
other platforms and other areas so um
yeah so we'll just leave it there
okay um i think that
the general tenor of the the
information we're getting from both the
chief executive and
the comms manager is that this is a
place we need to be
um but we need to manage it very
carefully
and we need to resource it properly and
i know that
from my perspective through the streets
alive
uh project you know i witnessed and
saw some of the the stuff that
sonia had to deal with and it wasn't
nice and it was there in volume
so we do need to take this seriously and
make sure we've got everybody protected
so that everybody feels as though they
can have their say
and not be attacked in a public setting
okay so it's open for discussion and or
amendment
receipt councillor heisted
you thank you like i'm certainly in
favor of the chief executive's
suggestion that
we may move away from three strikes
perhaps down to one i think we need to
be pretty firm in this area
but i guess from a health and safety
point of view
i guess i'm keen to understand what sort
of reporting mechanisms in place here
like it seems to be a an unmeasured
area we measure cuts and grazes and
and more serious incidents in our health
and safety report perhaps social media
needs to feature in our
in our health and safety monitoring
reports to order risk on a
just just to see you know what is the
volume of abusive
harassing emails i'm not sure how easy
that is to capture
but if staff are being abused whether
it's through
face-to-face or through social media i
think that is a concern
perhaps for the employer maybe not for
the council directly but
yeah interesting comments on that yeah
i'll be interested in
sonia's comments but from my observation
it's very
uh topic-dependent um and
it can be really good and then all of a
sudden depending on the topic
it can be quite nasty
through the chair um there shouldn't be
any staff abuse on social media anything
if there is comments up there where
staff are identified or even if they're
not identified
and counselors then those comments are
deleted
so they're only there until i can get to
them
i guess i get that but
somebody has to deal with them and
that's that's the issue here
yeah um council mcfarland then council
rude
um firstly obviously a compliment to the
congress manager in regard to having
seven and a half thousand followers on
the goal district council page you know
that's um
a credit to obviously the google council
itself to have
um whether it's good or bad we've still
got them there
yeah yeah any of that
sort of numbers is good numbers um
second thing would be in regard to the
discretion around
a ceo obviously has a more uh
water sword that's going to move quicker
than our commons manager but i think
there will be discretion in there anyway
would you not that if
econ's manager had an issue it would be
one strike
and they would be gone um i think that
would be the
the common sense approach and the third
matter was just in regard to peer
supervision obviously um
the economist manager has indicated that
she will deal with that problem but
i take it that would come under the hr
policy for her health and safety of our
staff
that she's able to access
the peer surveillance supervision or
some sort of supervision
um to a sister should should you have
any issues there uh because someone
still has to actually go to the coalface
and
remove the object so that's right
counselor
thank you your worship um i'm a fan of
the community being able to engage with
whatever the council is doing and like
everybody um
some of the recent comments have been
interesting to say the least and being a
small community we tend to know the
people involved
which sometimes has been an eye-opener
but what i
feel is the highest council of high
states remark
about the personal intrusion too on our
staff and we've got to be cognizant too
that
while our operations communications
manager is doing a great job
you know having to face those sort of
vitriolic remarks
all the time just i think we need to be
aware of that and be managing our staff
when it comes there as far as a health
and safety aspect goes
and i'm also very much in favor of the
one strike you're out
because um i think some of those people
have just been habitual offenders
so and the other thing i think we need
to take up
is along with the communications
manager's
[Music]
comment in the report is about moving to
instagram for some of our younger
members
i know a lot of the um
people i work with are definitely fall
into the younger age demographic
and that's what they use facebook is for
the elderly unfortunately
but yeah but definitely in favour of the
one strike thank you brahman
um glennis thank you worship
um i'm just what i'm wondering about is
with the one
strike what sort of things would there
be
i mean we don't want to be putting
anything in place where people can't
have a different opinion
so is it is it using bad language is it
um what i'm just wondering from sonia
how she would discern all of that
through the chair it would be in line
with their moderation policy
um you know you can't sit with
defamatory you can't call out staff you
can't detect stuff um you know
language um we do have a very strong
profanity filter so
in terms of bad language that doesn't
get through anyway it's all hidden
so it would have to be someone who made
you know racist slanderous
comments that that sort of thing i mean
if they just said i disagree
with a council policy and used very
colourful language
as long as it wasn't profanities i mean
we just have to i think i would look at
that as a
on the chin sort of thing really
i can just if i could just endorse that
um
council is that it's not to uh suppress
criticism of the council at all
and if someone says look you're a bunch
of idiots well that's just free speech
and that's fair
fair criticism you might disagree with
it but that's part of that's part
parcel of robust debate but as mrs
ginger said
it's about where it descends into
defamatory
highly abusive targeting individuals
racist
um sexist all that type of stuff that's
when
you as i understand that one strike is
well you get formally warned next time
you're gone burger
and you won't be participating you
permanently deleted from the opportunity
of participating in the debate
councillor could i just comment that the
fact we're called a pack of idiots would
probably be a very mild
century exactly
okay so i think the general tenor is
along those lines does anybody have any
different views around
where we go from here we definitely want
to keep the platforms
operating um we want to make sure that
they're operated
in a safe environment for
for the users of the platform but also
for for our staff
that have to deal with the comments that
are made
so if that is the intent of counsel
i think rather than having a formal
motion on this one if i could ask the
chief executive to
put his thoughts to this and
and put it in place yes
everybody comfortable with that okay
thank you councillors
and uh somebody like to move that we
received the reports
thank you councillor grant can secondary
council read
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
so item 13 uh 14
and 15 have been withdrawn from this
meeting or come to a subsequent meeting
and that leaves that brings us to the
end of our general business
we have um
two items in um in closed meeting
uh in committee um but somebody like to
move
i'll move that we move into